uh folks it looks to me
that california governor gavin newsom
is running for president in 2024.
california governor gavin newsom was
interviewed by fox la
and gavin newsom comes out swinging and
points out exactly what i've been saying
about democrats for a decade now gavin
newsom says we shouldn't be playing
defense we should be playing offense
democrats must be ferocious democrats
must be ruthless
this is exactly what i have been saying
for over a decade on this program
i am not saying
that gavin newsom is uh my preferred
politician that i agree with him on
every issue that he's the epitome of a
progressive
but this guy
identifies the exact issue is using the
right language is pointing out exactly
what i've been pointing out
he's coming out swinging take a look at
this from his interview over the weekend
you have to also recognize that what
you're up against and right now we're up
against the ruthlessness
of a republican party and i say that
not naively i don't say that even
that's not a cheap shot you see what's
happening to all the progress we've made
in the 21st century all of the rights
that we in many ways have taken for
granted that have been afforded since
the 60s are being rolled back in real
time this is a totally different moment
and we have to wake up with a different
mindset
and not just old mindset in terms of
just a collaborative mindset a cup of
tea and everyone's going to work
together to get along big ways
to advance the collective cause and
that's where the party needs to come in
democrats need the democratic party not
the president not a speaker not a
elected office holder guys he's pointing
out the absurdity of thinking you're
going to have a cup of tea with the
modern republican party and figure
things out and hash things out with them
he is exactly correct the party the
infrastructure i think has to organize
with more ferocity of focus
more determination to set the agenda set
the course and put the other party on
the defense they are dominating the
narrative the facts aren't on their side
but they're dominating there and in this
world right now you dominate the
narrative you win and that's what i'm
worried about and that's what i'm
expressing so this is all part of his
gubernatorial campaign for reelection
but he is doing a lot of different
things that suggest greater ambitions he
is running ads in florida saying hey you
want to come to the place with real
freedom leave florida come to california
he's doing interviews in which he is
addressing the major issues facing
structurally uh from a pr perspective
from a messaging perspective facing the
democratic party i'm not endorsing gavin
newsom he's not even running he's not
the most progressive
but this is a guy who could be president
now if he ran the smear campaign would
be brutal but it would also be pretty
toothless i mean okay stuff about his
dating history you know he he was once
married to kimberly guilfoyle now who is
now married to donald trump jr that's
weird that doesn't that that's you know
it makes it makes me question someone's
choices that's for sure he had this
dinner at the expensive restaurant the
french laundry during covid when you
weren't supposed to be doing that that
was wrong that was and he's gonna get
he's gonna get hit with that but
they are potentially going to expose
themselves if they have to run against
newsome because from what's known at
least right now
the criticisms and attacks on him would
be brutal but also quite toothless and
gavin newsom is 100 correct here they
have to be playing defense they're the
ones who are out of step with the views
of the american people why is it that
the left is constantly playing defense
they are the ones who are proposing
policy that would be disastrous for
millions of americans whether it's on
health care whether it's getting rid of
roe v whatever the case is
he's getting it and he is speaking about
it in a way that i'm not really hearing
anybody else talk about it right now
so
not endorsing anyone
it's very interesting that he has got
this messaging down pat because this is
the right messaging and by the way
this messaging is much more relevant on
the national stage and when you think
okay california california has large
geographic areas that are conservative
but from a population standpoint
california is not conservative and when
he talks about the strategy and tactics
that are required against this
republican party
it's fine to keep it in mind if you're
running for governor in california but
really it's relevant nationally so this
is super interesting we'll have this
interview on our instagram at david
pakman show check it out tell me what
you think i'm liking what i'm hearing
i think this is the biggest discount
that any sponsor has ever offered on the
david pakman show this is crush organics
crush organics loves the show so much
they're giving my viewers 50 off their
entire collection of organic cbd
products when you use the code pacman
i'm the only show
where you can get this big a discount
that i like and for each sale crush
organics will donate ten dollars to the
last prisoner project that's a really
great non-profit helps to
free non-violent drug offenders and
reform drug laws very important and it
doesn't stop there anyone who uses my
code also gets a free jar
of cbd gummies or a jar of cbd topical
cream crush has only the best organic
cbd whether you're looking for oils
creams or edibles so that's 50 off and a
free jar of gummies or topical cream and
10 bucks towards creating real change in
our justice system go to crush organics
dot u s
and use the code pacman the link is down
below